esse negócio de cada que se mexe só
também não gosto não importa que abre só
cadeira de balanço que se mexe só ai a
galera começa a conversar com o espírito
da casa né que isso é normal muito bom é
interagir né a gente precisa de União
Jesus disse para amar o próximo ah mas
não tá vivo mas tá próximo tá ali na
casa ah mospeito também conversa com ele
interação eu assistindo aqui no cinema a
pessoa que não olhou né só uma cabecinha
se mexendo com verde cara vem falar na
outra pessoa atrasada chegando deu
vontade de pegar você vai tomar no teu
cu filha da aí tem hora do filme
que o espírito se manifesta na menina Ah
e a cadeira voando é mesa batendo mesa
voando nas cadeiras bate na mesa gente
correndo para um lado e para o outro
quebrando tudo arrebentando quebrando
tudo parece uma roda pano todo mundo
gritando não aparece o diabo da Freira
no canto do quarto mano
o Espírito só aparece Encanto hein
espírito tem essas Besteira isso aqui
aparece se for nos cantos tá deitado
aqui olha pra mim se tiver deitado pra
cá por isso que quando eu fiz a casa eu
vou fazer ela toda Redonda que é para o
diabo não apareceu em